ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DAILY DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL ALL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND HARRY OSHA REVENUES.
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
AWHILE BACK I WAS ASKED IF I
COULD LIVE ANYWHERE.
IN IN ANY TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
THE WORLD.
WHERE AND WHEN WOULD THAT BE?
I'M SURE SOME OF US HAVE
WONDERED THIS BEFORE.
STRETCHING MY IMAGINATION I
ENVISIONED A NUMBER OF ERRORS IN
PLACES THAT WOULD BE INTRIGUING
TO EXPERIENCE.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THE MANY
COUNTRIES AND CULTURES IN THE
WORLD I ADMIRE.
IN HISTORIC MOMENTS THAT WOULD
BE FASCINATING TO BE A PART OF
AFTER CONSIDERING THE MANY
PLACES A MOMENTS IN HISTORY THAT
I COULD BE.
IT WAS NO DOUBT THAT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THIS MOMENT RIGHT NOW IS
EXACTLY WHERE I WISH TO BE.
I FEEL FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A
PLACE AND THAT IS ALWAYS.
TRYING TO BE BETTER TO BE HERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
WHAT MEMBERS WHO RESPECT IN
EMBRACE DIVERSITY?
IN RESPONSE TO EVEN THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF ISSUES ALWAYS
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
I AM FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A
PLACE AND TIME THAT IS ALWAYS
TRYING TO BE BETTER.
AS DOROTHY CONCLUDED IN THE
CLASSIC WIZARD OF OZ.
THERE TRULY IS NO PLACE LIKE
HOME.
LET US EVEN MORE TRIED TO BE
GRATEFUL TO BE RIGHT HERE.
IN RIGHT NOW.
HOW FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A PLACE
IN TIME THAT IS ALWAYS TRYING TO
BE BETTER?
NUMBER ME DOWN SOON THE KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PLEDGING ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF OUR GREAT NATION PLACE YOUR
HANDS OF THE HEART VETERANS MAY
SALUTE READY TO BEGIN.
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO WHICH STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WE WILL MATCH THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH
NINETEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON
LOCUSTS USER BONTA MOVES IN
MISTER FLORES SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE IS A BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GARCIA MULLIN
AND QUIRK SILVA FOR ILLNESS
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MISSIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME ARE DONE
JUST BEGUN IN GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX IN
WITHDRAWAL ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
FOUR THROUGH ONE TWENTY ONE
INCLUSIVE BY SOMEONE MEMBER TING
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN
ORDER THEM TO THE SECOND READING
FILE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE AS WE WE
OBJECT THAT'S FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
MEMBERS THE REPUBLICANS ARE
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS THAT WE SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX WE WILL
TAKE A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON
SUSPENDING THE RULES THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTER MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
AND NO VOTES.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORES ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
YEAH ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE PLEASE VOTE [inaudible]
WORK WELL [inaudible]
HOLD ON WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE.
ICE FORTY SEVEN NO SIXTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN FOR YOUR
MISSION THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
THE COMMITTEE.
AB TWO THREE TWO CERVANTES FROM
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AB FIVE FORTY THREE SMITH FROM
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TO THE PROCREATION COMMITTEE.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY SIX REVERSE
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO ADD TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT MURATSUCHI
FROM THE NATIONAL RESOURCE
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AND AB FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE JONES
SAWYER FROM THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM SEVENTY SIX A
BEFORE NINETY SIX LOW FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I MOVED TO RE REFER AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX AND BY BAUER-KAHAN
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE TO
THE WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
YOU RISE.
HOUSE SPEAKER WE OBJECT AS FOR
ROLL CALL VOTE OKAY WE WILL TAKE.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE OBJECTING TO
RE REFER ALL OF THE MEASURE
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS THAT EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY NINE BE REFERRED FROM
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE A PROCEDURAL
VOTE ON THE MOTION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO GO
PLEASE VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED OF A
THIRTY WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FIFTEEN THE MOTION CARRIES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IF WE CAN PLEASE GET
MEMBERS TO GO BACK TO THEIR
SEATS AND PLEASE KEEP THE
CONVERSATIONS DOWN TO A MINIMUM
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS.
THAT COULD BE INTRODUCING GAS WE
WANT TO GIVE OUR FULL ATTENTION
AND RESPECT TO THOSE MEMBERS AS
WELL SO THE GAS AND VISITING OUR
CHAMBERS TODAY SO PLEASE KEEP
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM THANK
YOU
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MR PEROT WHO
INTRODUCES GAS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION THEY'VE
BEEN HERE THIS WEEK ON THEIR
ANNUAL LOBBY DATA EDUCATE US ON
ISSUES FACING THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND ALSO HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
INTRODUCING A CONSTITUENT DAVE
NORA WHO OWNS NORTHLAND
LANDSCAPING AND MY DISTRICT SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS. TO THE
BUILDING TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO AN ADDITIONAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION MISTER HOLDEN
IS RECOGNIZED FOR AN
INTRODUCTION PLEASE GIVE HIM
YOUR RESPECT.
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE
A GROUP OF STUDENTS.
WHO ARE VISITING FROM THE
CLAREMONT COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT -- THEY'RE HERE TODAY
AT THE CAPITOL AS PART OF A
CALIFORNIA POLITICS SEMINAR AT
CLAREMONT MCKENNA COLLEGE.
TAUGHT BY KEN MILLER A PROFESSOR
OF GOVERNMENT.
OF THE STUDENTS COME FROM FOR
THE FIVE CLAREMONT COLLEGES
CLAREMONT MCKENNA CREMONA PITZER
AND SCRIPTS COLLEGE.
OVER THE YEARS MANY ALUMNI OF
THIS CLASS OF GOING ON TO WORK
IN SACRAMENTO.
AS CAPITAL FELLOWS IN OTHER
POSITIONS PLEASE WELCOME THESE
WONDERFUL YOUNG PEOPLE FROM MY
DISTRICT THE CLAREMONT COLLEGES
WHO ARE HERE VISITING TODAY.
SPECIAL WELCOME TO ALL OF OUR
GUESTS TODAY WILL BE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMONS SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWO WITH THE MEMONS
1-322-851-1213 WITH AMENDMENTS
TEN SIXTY WITH THE MOMENT. SEVEN
HUNDRED AT THE MOMENT FIVE
FOURTEEN EIGHT FIFTY THREE SIX
NINETY FIVE WITH THE MOMENTS
NINE FORTY THREE WITH THE MEMONS
ONE THOUSAND WITH THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN FORTY WITH THE MEMONS.
THIRTEEN TWENTY WITH THE MEMONS
1-729-445-1460 952-551-62660
989-313-5750. 865-255-3814
243-647-3540. 658-860-9611
619-903-1011. TWELVE THIRTY ONE
NORTH MA'AM IT'S FIVE FORTY
EIGHT WITH THE MAMMOTH NINETY
ONE AT THE MOMENT. TEN SIXTY
FIVE SIXTY NINE WITH THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN EIGHT YOU AT THE
MOMENT SIX THIRTY NINE AT THE
MOMENT ONE EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT TO TWENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR SEVENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS NINE EIGHTEEN WITH
THE MEMBERS. TEN NINETY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE THIRTY
THREE WITH THE MEMONS NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
FIVE NINETY SIX WITH THE MOMENT.
SEVEN NINETY FIVE WITH THE
MOMENT FOR FIFTY THREE WITH THE
MOMENT SIXTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
AND EIGHT FIFTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS.
I'LL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY NINE THROUGH
SEVENTY FIVE WILL BE PASSED IN
RETAINS.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO LEGAL
EIGHT NINETY NINE I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE NINE
FORTY SIX I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SOME LEGAL TWELVE OH THREE
I SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO LEGAL SEVEN EIGHTY ONE I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO ONLY ABLE
TO FIFTY SIX I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY I
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY APRIL FIFTH THERE IS NO
FLOOR SESSION AND NOTE CHECK IN
SESSION.
ON MONDAY APRIL EIGHTH WE HAVE
FLOOR SESSION A ONE PM.
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR OR TAKE YOUR SEATS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
MISS COM LONGER DAD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF YOUR MEANS ASKING DOWN.
ALSO KNOWN AS NIPSEY HUSSLE WHO
WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED ON MARCH
THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN NIPSEY WAS A
RESIDENT OF THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
NANCY WAS BORN AUGUST FIFTEENTH
HE WAS A LEO.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND RAISED
IN THE HYDE PARK NEIGHBORHOOD OF
SOUTH LA.
HE ATTENDED SCHOOLS IN THE CITY
INCLUDING JOHN BURROUGHS MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
GRAMMY NOMINATED RAPPER NIPSEY
HUSSLE SAID IN ONE OF HIS LYRICS
FIND YOUR PURPOSE OR YOU'RE
WASTING AIR.
NIPSEY WAS KNEE DEEP IN FINDING
HIS PURPOSE WHEN HE WAS KILLED.
HE WAS A PIONEER.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE HEARD FROM
WHICH HE CAME.
AND IT NEITHER REBUKED IT NOR
FOR GOT IT IN HIS QUEST FOR
REDEFINING SELF DETERMINATION AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL ISN'T ON HIS OWN
TERMS.
HE PLAYED THE LONG GAME ONCE
TELLING SOMEONE THAT HE FIRST
HEARD OF SNOOP DOGG RAP AT AGE
NINE AND IT WASN'T UNTIL HE WAS
THIRTY THREE THAT HE RELEASED
HIS FIRST STUDIO ALBUM.
IN TWENTY TEN THE A CLAIM HE HAS
A CLAIM MIX TAPE BULLET SAYING
GOT NO NAME VOLUME TO RECEIVE
GREAT NOTORIETY LANDING HIM ON
THE COVER OF THE FRESHMAN X. X.
ELLE MAGAZINE.
A MAJOR MILESTONE FOR EMERGING
HIP HOP ARTISTS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN HE SOLD ONE
THOUSAND MIX TAPES OF HIS ALBUM
CRENSHAW FOR A HUNDRED DOLLARS
EACH.
ON FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NIPSEY RELEASED HIS
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED GRAMMY
NOMINATED DEBUT ALBUM VICTORY
LAP WHICH WAS A CULMINATION OF
ALL TWELVE OF HIS MIXTAPES
INCLUDING THE MARATHON SERIES.
BUT HE WAS MORE THAN A MUSICIAN
AND RAPPER HE WAS ALSO AN
ENTREPRENEUR DEVELOPER TECH
MAVERICK INVESTOR ROLE MODEL.
ALWAYS WHILE STAYING TRUE TO THE
GAME AND TO HIS COMMUNITY.
NIPSEY OPEN THE MARATHON STORE A
CLOTHING STORE IN CRENSHAW THAT
IS THE WORLD'S FIRST SMART STORE.
HE BUILT BASKETBALL COURTS TO
THROUGH OUT THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HE WAS A
PARTNER IN DESTINATION CRENSHAW
A MULTI MILE LONG PUBLIC ART
PROJECT.
ANY PARTNERED WITH THAT BURGER
ON CRENSHAW LOGO DESIGNS FOR
UNIFORMS.
NIPSEY ALSO INVESTED IN SEVERAL
BUSINESS VENTURES IN SOUTH LA
INCLUDING THE RE OPENING OF THE
WORLD ON WHEELS SKATING RINK. TO
RESTAURANTS AND SLAWSON IN
CRENSHAW A BARBER SHOP AND
VECTOR NINETY ONE OF THE FIRST
WORK SPACES IN INCUBATORS AND
SOUTH LA DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
BLACK AND BROWN BROWN
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN SOUTH LA.
HE SAID HE WANTED TO MAKE
CRENSHAW FEEL LIKE FAIRFAX AND
HE WANTED TO ATTRACT BUSINESS TO
AREAS DEEMED UNSAFE OR
FORGETTABLE [inaudible]
IRONICALLY.
NIPSEY WAS GUNNED DOWN BY THE
STREET [inaudible]
NOTHING.
ABOUT A PREMATURE DEATH.
EVER FEELS FAIR.
OR JUST.
HIS DEATH WAS TRAGIC AND
UNNECESSARY.
THE KIND OF KILLING THAT HAPPENS
WHEN FOLKS FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO LOSE.
AND FOR CRENSHAW THIS KIND OF
SELF INFLICTED PAIN.
HURTS THE MOST.
USUALLY WHEN PEOPLE MAKE IT.
THEY GET OUT OF THE HOOD.
BUT GETTING OUT DOESN'T ALWAYS
MEAN GETTING SAFE.
NIPSEY IS LIVE.
WASN'T ABOUT ASKING WHY WE
SHOULD LEAVE OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
HIS LIFE WAS ABOUT ASKING WHY
NOT INVEST IN THEM.
IN DEMAND THAT OTHERS DO AS WELL.
HAVING HAD A LONG HISTORY IN
GETTING CULTURE NIPSEY
COMMUNICATED TO A DEMOGRAPHIC OF
PEOPLE OFTEN OVERLOOKED.
AND DISMISSED BY MOST OF SOCIETY.
THESE ARE BLACK AND BROWN MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE RAISED AN
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
FEEL THAT THE BULLET IS THE ONLY
OPTION IN LIFE.
AND SURVIVING BY ANYTHING THAT'S
NECESSARY IS ALL THAT WE CAN DO.
MY HOPE IS THAT SOMEONE FROM THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
SOMEONE WHO HAS SOME JUICE LIKE
NIPSEY HUSSLE.
TAKES UP THE MANTLE AND BUILDS
ON THE LEGACY THAT HE WAS
DEVELOPING FOR CRENSHAW FOR THE
FIFTY FOURTH AND FOR ALL OF US
THAT COME FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES.
MY HEART AND CONDOLENCES GO OUT
TO HIS FAMILY INCLUDING HIS SON
CROSS HIS DAUGHTER IMANI HIS
FIANCEE LAUREN HIS MOTHER AND
HIS FATHER HIS BROTHER SAM HIS
SISTER SAMANTHA.
AND HIS ENTIRE TEAM.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF ARMIES
ASK ADAM ALSO KNOWN AS NIPSEY
HUSSLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED IN RETAINS ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES IN MR
CHAN'S SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
APRIL EIGHTH AT ONE PM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHEN AB. SEVEN FOUR TWO TWO ONE
FROM NOTES NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEN
AS LEVEL SEVENTY FOUR NOTES NOT
VOTING